i i i don't know this news show with him
and his girlfriend
listen they're talking about what you go
through this is interesting actually
okay
anybody else just checking sex
and like i have yes and like look at who
i'm calling or like
no i don't look at who you're calling
okay do you like scroll through my dms
making sure i'm not having any interest
don't go through your dm's no
talk that [ __ ] i went through all your
stuff you go through my dms all the time
you go through my phone
all the time damn that's he supposed to
do that i don't i
no if i have to do that we're not meant
to be together yeah
all your deal is yours your phone and
yeah what are you doing
do you guys do that though do you guys
shouldn't know oh no i don't have access
to your girl's phone or the other
side like your instagram and [ __ ] no
just actual phone like to open it up
no yeah we know both each other's codes
okay i don't know all girls go
like i'll go days without my phone like
on the weekends i'm hard to get ahold of
because my phone's gone my girl just
gave me her code i just
go to go through a phone call them six
figures still there okay he's just
making sure he's here
he's still doing it and she just closed
she on set right now
hey baby she's an actress now she's a
product uh producer for lion's gate
well he's just airing out her all the
time we're comfortable now i'm
picking my feet up come on bro we got
the z in the back in front of her
hell no i won't mess it up now no i'll
tell you a true story
this dude no keep it professional no
talk about for farting no i don't never
i keep it sexy yeah yeah we got kids and
stuff yeah so it's like
already it's like i'm cleaning up we're
cleaning up [ __ ] and stuff all the time
like
i hate farting i hate when people just
do it really
oh it's tricking for oh my gosh i threw
a cd on my homie's face and it
split his eye open because he farted in
my room um just in you
he's just let out a fight he was like
and i was like
this is your anger days though yeah you
wouldn't do that now would i do
no i wouldn't throw a cd where am i
going to get a cd you could throw your
girl down fire on you does she nope
yeah that's frowned upon i don't do it
around her either because it's just like
yeah
like we don't have to be like you know
it's weird some guys that do like dutch
oven their girl and chin like what's
wrong oh that's yeah
yeah yes what's the nature hey you know
what a dutch oven is no i don't you
fart underneath the covers and then you
keep that person in there yeah
you're like hot boxing them who no no i
don't do that weird [ __ ] don't you guys
do that i don't i don't get it man
what's your question i know
that is a fart from your vagina oh dude
call me a queef
okay oh i didn't know i didn't know that
yeah but no
i thought you misspelled you gotta keep
it sexy man yeah just like i hate that
[ __ ] i'm just like miss hey
you know farting's not cool no one wants
to smell that [ __ ] yeah
hate it like it's like one of my biggest
pet peeves interesting
like like i hate parkour yeah yeah wow
i gotta go crazy oh damn so yeah like
whoopee cushions
[ __ ] what we got those are old school
man i know [ __ ] i did that bro i was bad
as hell i used to stay bringing them
into class
when i got off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro
i figured out what you look like i'm
like what this front of a bunch of other
comics i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son